we got a corona Roubaix a corona virus
related king under sting it okay hey
guys I'm Aaron from Vancouver Washington
and I've got a king at our sting it for
you
coronavirus themed pickup lines anyways
thanks for keeping us entertained
through all this Gang Gang buzz buzz and
he's got some examples okay
Corona pickup lines yeah I'll be the
covet you'd be the 19 cuz together I
think we'd make a pretty sick couple
yeah I tested positive for being your
next boyfriend huh I've kid name's Aaron
I'm off the burning in my chest is a
symptom of the corona virus or it's just
the feelings I get from seeing you two
to 240 all I know is that someone will
[ __ ] with those lines that's where
we've got a society we've really
bottomed out and turns of [ __ ] sting
you man I don't think that those people
aren't digging those lines man I think
some of these thirst traps would they're
sitting at home right now taking
pictures of their ass get on the damn
girl you look sick she freaks out like
not that body sick yeah yeah and roll
right over quarantine up with some home
these chicks are freaking out they're
gonna die alone pussy's never been more
bargain-basement I just got out your
shop Brian what if what if they find out
Corona is easily transmitted through
sperm yeah no more creating your own
sink like I concentrated in sperm and
then you butthole absorbs like a lot of
people they don't want to bring kids
into this sick world right right doing
anal is probably at all-time high
yeah Nino's people crushing that ass ass
is bad cuz for a while
hey cuz when I was growing up like 80s
90s if your girl didn't give up the ass
like at least once a year you break up
with her and everyone would understand
but these days Mexicans nobody's really
anal so dead right now
no no it's like nobody-nobody
divorce their wife because they don't
give a maim nobody in the 80
yeah yeah you go to the judge you could
euler the judge say you know it's
overrated Internet arrest it's best to
threaten like your girlfriend you
thought right yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna put
her in your ass and just this year oh
wow just this year yeah the threat
that's all I want yeah and then you
threaten with like you put a little
thumb in there like I get bit you gotta
trust that ass if you don't trust that
ass why you wanna put a condom oh my
first my thumb first before if I try to
put it into something you put a condom
on your thumb wow man how's that going
what do you guys do if you guys are
venturing into the dark of dark web the
dark web or you mean that talk about
Koreatown yeah baby
first of all we make sure they take a
good [ __ ] and then shower Wow and then I
respect that man before you hop run to
the bathroom and she does some NASCAR
[ __ ] on her [ __ ] get in there clean
it all out
throw a little spray on that that's all
I'm looking for hey back up
like maybe 16 years ago
oh yeah first time years ago I here's
gonna turn out one of my students
produced like bottom-of-the-barrel born
like it was only I know that only he was
a category I'm poor no bottom the bare
office oh no I didn't really know at
that point I just nearly produce porn so
I thought damn like you know he must be
getting a lot of hot chicks you know
what I mean right talk about his way I
didn't know the level and then I said
dude a you know if I ever could hang out
on the set I'd love to hang out you know
I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm a gold set oh yeah
every got hot go our installer to be an
orgy and I'm like I want so we invited
me goes hey dude come on dick come on
down there's I'm filming at this place
in in like when Hannah Rama City yeah
I'm like okay so dude I was stoked focus
where would you wear I don't remember
what I wore yeah but I don't remember
what I wore but you're not hard driving
oh I get there I stood I was gone dude I
slept the [ __ ] I got on my ground was
gone and then he called me on the I'm on
the [ __ ] 405 getting a [ __ ] out of
there
and he calls where'd you go bro she
wants to [ __ ] you I'm like dude sorry
thank y'all take a rain check
were you going she wants to [ __ ] you yes
no dude that was gone are you surprised
at porn so it wants to [ __ ] that's kind
of what they do you want to see our
sausage made Eddie no Hey one time I was
it wasn't what I imagined was it it's
cold low level do low level I went to a
porn shoot nad catering there was a
caterer that sounds like Andrew Blake's
that sounds nice what else you got that
good porn
wait we did we answer um yeah we did we
you stung the pickup line you say you
know I and I like it I think time crisis
I think people use a little humor these
girls are locked up bored as [ __ ] I'm
locked up yeah they are I think that
women are not doing any sex or anything
like that right now I think everybody
shutting it down I think people are
gonna be a lot of Corona baby how do
they all think there are I guarantee I'm
juggling mule in their homes right now
get out comb your hair live some life I
didn't a wash so surprised
[Music]
the king
[Music]